[Music]
hello there and welcome to the uk's only
daily climate news show where we track
the changes happening to our world right
now and challenge those coming up with
the solutions president biden has
pledged to double the 5.7 billion
dollars that the u.s had already
committed to help developing countries
cope with climate change mr biden made
the announcement at the united nations
general assembly in new york where he
warned we had entered a decisive decade
for our world his intervention came
after boris johnson called on rich
nations to make good their promise to
support poorer countries in their fight
against climate change well coming up
we'll look at whether the u.s pledge
could help make november's cop 26 summit
in glasgow a success but first let's
hear what mr biden had to say this
afternoon
in april
i announced the united states will
double our public international
financing to help developing nations
tackle the climate crisis and today
i'm proud to announce that we'll work
with the congress to double that number
again
including for adaptation efforts
this will make the united states a
leader in public climate finance and
with our added support together with
increased private capital
and other from other donors
will be able to meet the goal of
mobilizing
100 billion dollars
to support climate action in developing
nations
president biden speaking a short time
ago well our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter
explains just why the funding increase
could prove so important the united
nations general assembly in new york is
an important staging post on the way to
the cop 26 climate change summit which
is being held in glasgow later this year
at the summit we're told the focus will
be on coal cars
cash and trees and today it's cash in
the spotlight that's because back in
2009 rich countries pledged to give a
hundred billion dollars per year from
2020 to support poorer nations as they
adapt to the effects of climate change
but that target has been missed the most
recent oecd report estimates that only
79.6 billion dollars in public and
private funding has been delivered so
far
america had taken some of the blame for
that promising just 5.7 billion dollars
a year which critics said was nowhere
near enough given the size of its
economy but now america has promised to
double its annual contribution to over
11 billion dollars potentially
encouraging other nations who might have
been holding back to do the same
the us now joins the uk which has
pledged to deliver around three billion
a year over the next five years as a
leader in climate finance funding
so why does all of this matter so much
well the cop 26 climate meeting is just
weeks away now and developing countries
like indonesia and others have said they
are willing to consider tougher carbon
emissions targets but only if they are
funded as promised to them it's a matter
of trust and good faith it may be just a
number but that 100 billion
really matters
so after his address to the un in new
york mr biden is now back at the white
house where he's due to welcome boris
johnson this evening in the past few
minutes he's been reacting to mr biden's
pledge
this is very good news in the sense that
the united states has stepped up to the
plate with a a massive contribution of a
very substantial contribution uh 11.2
billion dollars i think it is
and that's a that's
a very very good start it means that
we're
a long way towards the the goal that we
need to achieve but there's still
further to go and uh there are still
countries around the world that will be
looking to us in the developed world to
support them as they make the transition
to low-carbon technologies to fight
climate change uh but there's no
question that this this american action
today has been a big lift and will
really help us to get there
well our u.s correspondent martha calner
is in washington for us now martha boris
johnson there very buoyant how much
credit do you think he can take for this
announcement by joe biden ahead of cop
26.
i think he'll certainly try to frame
this as a major victory for the uk and
for his personal lobbying on climate
change ahead of the cop 26 conference
which is viewed as a home conference in
the uk in glasgow
in november he's described it as a
moment of truth for the world on climate
change and he's also been urging for
some time for major economies and those
major emitters of carbon to take the
lead on this and he's got this result as
he'll frame it from president biden
committing to double the amount that
america um is giving to developing
countries as they fight climate change
too from just under six billion dollars
and to just under 12 billion dollars
president biden incredibly impassioned
about climate during that speech and he
said it was a decade that will quite
literally determine our future and he
spoke he said will we suffer a merciless
march of ever worsening droughts and
floods more intense fires and hurricanes
longer heat waves and rising seas he now
has to convince a domestic audience that
human um human fall is
a result of climate change is the cause
of climate change apologies
okay martha in washington thank you
well joining me now is tina stegey
climate envoy of the marshall islands
the u.s geological survey has forecast
that some of the islands will be
submerged by 2035.
so tina tell me
your reaction to this this huge
announcement by the president
yes i've watched that speech like a hawk
um and i just have to say i breathe a
huge sigh of relief and i was energized
um because this announcement is
significant it gets us so much closer to
where we need to be
and
i just think we now have some momentum
in the next few weeks going forward to
cop
so tell me how will this money be spent
somewhere like the marshall islands
in the marshall islands we've taken a
leadership role in
submitting higher emissions targets
and we have plans in place for how to do
that we have an electricity roadmap to
transition us to renewable energies
but that roadmap is not at this moment
uh funded and we've been working hard to
get that funding and this kind of pledge
signals that you know
we're in this together that uh not just
the u.s but donor countries in general
they have our back and we can only meet
this crisis you know
with a global response
we're looking at some of the images of
the marshall islands you really are at
the front line of climate change aren't
you give me a sense of how difficult
things there are right now
it has been a very very difficult
year and a half
two years particularly with kovid
and
the restrictions on travel and the
economic difficulties posed by shutdowns
and having to manage both covet and the
climate crisis at the same time it's
it's really a textbook example of sort
of the cascading effects of these crises
and so
seeing that uh countries like the united
states and others are are willing to
step up and serve and join hands with us
to really respond
um puts
gives us you know hope for the future
okay tina stegy great to have you with
us many thanks
thank you
and we'll be discussing if 100 billion
dollars is enough for developing
countries to take real action on climate
change today i'm joined by the travel
writer juliet kinsman and george monbio
from the guardian that's coming up in a
few minutes time
now in some of today's other climate
news the government has reached an
agreement with cf industries to restart
co2 production the us fertilizer company
which is one of just two main co2
suppliers to the uk has suspended
operations because of the high cost of
energy leading to a national shortage
greenhouse gas emissions fell by 13 in
the uk last year it's the largest drop
since records began data from the office
of national statistics shows overall
emissions dropped by around 72 million
tons between 2019 and 2020 as people
stayed at home during the pandemic the
transport sector perhaps unsurprisingly
was the biggest driver of falling
emissions with a record 40 percent
decline
and mps are recommending that washing
machines should be fitted with filters
which can catch micro plastic fibers
from clothes a new all-party
parliamentary group has been set up to
look at the environmental harm caused by
those tiny fragments it wants to see new
rules requiring manufacturers to fit the
filters from 2025.
now scientists say one of the world's
biggest and most expensive fish may have
returned to uk waters because of rising
sea temperatures atlantic bluefin tuna
are now swimming off the southwest coast
more than half a century since they were
last spotted now the government has
recruited 15 fishermen to track the fish
for a scientific study which sky's dan
whitehead was given exclusive access to
there we go it's been 60 years since
they last swam in our waters
now atlantic bluefin tuna are back
in such numbers that government
scientists are working with cornish
fishermen to find out why
we need to know what's going on we need
to know the numbers we need to know
where they are how many are there the
age structure as much as we can get
really
catching bluefin tuna is banned in the
uk but this study is giving recreational
anglers the opportunity to finally reel
one in it's the first time i've ever
caught a bluefin tuna yeah how's it feel
brilliant absolutely brilliant to do it
in british waters
it's it's
something i thought i'd never do a
little bit of pork police chris
the fish are tagged before being
released getting the study to this stage
has seen fishermen go back to the
classroom
they've been trained by government
scientists in how to safely handle the
fish the study runs till november with
the hope that tanks will provide answers
as to why they've returned so one of the
factors could be climate factors
so increased water temperatures it could
be an increase in the numbers and
distribution of the bait fish which they
predate upon
or other factors that are as yet unknown
this is citizen science in action
fishermen working alongside government
teams to track this magnificent fish but
the return of atlantic bluefin tuna to
uk waters could also provide a new
lifeline for cornwall's communities
70
[Music]
73
unlike other countries the uk doesn't
have a commercial or recreational quota
to catch bluefin tuna skippers hope this
study could change that
this huge fish is back in the southwest
for good
some good news for once well do stay
with us coming up after the break we're
going to be discussing is 100 billion
dollars enough money for developing
countries and whether insulate britain's
protests are working i'm going to be
joined by travel writer juliet kinsman
and guardian columnist george monbio
that's coming up in a couple of minutes
[Music]
[Music]
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do they say they'll be
killed
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day can't access those and knees
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us there are
people wading through it
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment
i don't like the chinese government it's
true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
[Music]
here and just one of them is the size of
around 31 000 football pitches
shivorn robins sky news bangkok
[Music]
we don't understand that every lake or a
pond is a habitat in itself which houses
frogs snakes crabs turtles birds so many
different life forms human beings
directly depend on underground water
source so a lake or a pond is necessary
to replenish these groundwater resources
[Music]
hello again welcome back to the daily
climate show here on sky news and we're
getting straight into discussing the
climate issues of the day with the
travel writer juliette kinsman and
george monbio environmentalist and
guardian columnist there they are well
let's kick off with joe biden's pledge
ahead of cop 26 that the us will double
the money it's making available to help
developing countries cope with climate
change very good evening to both of you
george why don't we start with you first
i'm sure you heard the announcement
great news isn't it
well sort of i mean finally the
government of the us is making good
pledges which are what are they now 12
years old um and to be honest it
scarcely touches the sides i mean this
is a massive amount of investment
required to help poorer nations
it also should represent just a small
part of the huge climate debt which rich
nations owe to the poor ones due to the
impacts of our greenhouse gases
well hang on a minute george it's
doubling climate finance to 11 billion
dollars it's a huge amount of money and
it's good in the sense that it shows
that the us is leading the way but also
that the uk is able to make a difference
ahead of head of cop 26.
well look any increment in money is good
but it's still i mean it sounds like a
lot it is a lot but it's tiny i mean
really really tiny when you think of all
the nations which are already suffering
climate crises right now and are going
to suffer much worse climate crises as a
result primarily
of the greenhouse gases that the rich
nations have produced so we did this to
them and this is a very small reparation
by comparison and also far too little
money to actually help them out of the
emergencies which we've landed on them
yeah um juliette let's get your thoughts
on this this is what president biden
said earlier let's remind ourselves he
said it's a chance for each of our
countries to invest in ourselves and our
own futures uh are you confident that
this money even if it's not enough will
be spent wisely and won't be fritted
away
oh my goodness no way i mean it's
already got shades of austin powers
around it you know these huge just
numbers said what do they mean where are
they going where is this money going
what's being done with it um what are
the strings attached because you know
however money circulates generally and
certainly from the wealthy polluting
countries there are strings attached
they want to see return on investment so
i would love it a lot more if i could
hear where that money was going they
were investing in the education of women
in remote rural areas which is actually
tackling one of the the biggest
challenges causing climate emergency how
people ask you know well it tackles uh
population situation women get married
later they have fewer healthier children
they're better equipped to deal with
extreme weather um they contribute
better to the economy so these are the
kind of conversations i want to hear and
i also will get much more excited when i
hear about the perpetrators the
polluters instead of these gestures and
giving money to the poorer countries
saying this is how we're bringing down
our emissions these are the numbers and
this is how we're doing better instead
of trying to do that
that leads very nicely um on to my next
question actually uh president bolsonaro
of brazil he said today we do hope
industrialized countries will actually
fulfill their commitments to climate
funding i mean juliet there's an irony
there isn't there that he is lecturing
the rest of us on how to tackle climate
change
absolutely look i i don't want to hear
about these pleasures and these
commitments i just want to see the
numbers of of emissions being brought
down from the industrialized ways of the
wealthier countries um rather than this
sort of atonement and whatever you want
to call it offsetting almost um we
really want to understand how the causes
of the climate emergency are being are
being tackled
okay stay where you are both if you're
going to move on to another topic now
insulate britain you may have seen this
today they block sections of the m25 for
the fifth time in a week and they say
actions will continue until the
government commits to insulating homes
but is this disruptive form of protest
damaging their cause uh juliet what do
you think good thing bad thing
well so look insulation is actually a
topic close to my heart you know 20
percent of emissions in the uk at
greenhouse gas emissions come from the
warming of the places we live in and we
work in so it's an issue so thank you
yes shine a light on it when they first
did this in august the first protest
yeah
okay well let's ask george then because
george this is what uh the police said
today protesters have put their own
lives as well as those of others at risk
i mean stopping traffic on the m25 is
hugely dangerous it's a pretty stupid
way to get your message out there isn't
it
you have to draw attention to this issue
and civil disobedience is an essential
way of doing so it's been an essential
protest tactic all the way through the
suffragettes gandhi martin luther king
when you have an issue which is being
comprehensively neglected
by those in power you have to use the
most powerful means at your disposal to
try to get it on the front page in front
of people's minds and
disruptive civil disobedience has time
and again proved to be that most
powerful means and of course yeah it is
inconvenient to people but while we're
talking about the inconvenience on the
m25 just a couple of days ago motorways
in france were flooded
probably as a result of climate
breakdown and that took an awful lot
longer to clear and that is a glimpse of
the future we're going to have
repeatedly
unless we start to bring in
radical aims to insulate britain's core
yeah juliet like the suffragettes
well i just went to their website
there's no information on how i can
actually insulate better give me some
tools
oh you mean on their website you you're
not getting the information you need
even if you wanted to insulate yeah okay
i i get that i get that point i mean
george i have to say one
person on the radio this morning was
saying he was trying to drive his mother
to hospital because she'd had a stroke
they got to hospital hours late and as a
result she's partially paralyzed
well i i'm really sorry to hear that and
you know obviously
yeah um you know bad stuff does happen
but you know we're facing disruption
which is going to be killing hundreds of
millions of people unless we get a grip
on this you know this this is huge i
mean i don't think anyone really can get
their head around
the level of suffering
which we're likely to experience unless
we stop climate breakdown from happening
and it seems to me that the only people
who are taking it seriously
are protesters who are almost putting
their lives on the line to try to draw
attention to the massive neglect of this
issue by those in power and these
protests would not be necessary if those
in power were actually interested in
saving lives and stopping the
catastrophe which is coming our way okay
we're out of time we could debate this
much longer but george julia always
always good to speak to you thank you
very much indeed and that's everything
from us for today on the show tomorrow
our activist michaela loach also tom
burke director of the climate think tank
e3g but do stay tuned coming up next on
sky news tonight we'll have more on
president biden's pledge to help build a
stronger global community and coverage
of his meeting with boris johnson thanks
for watching we'll see you next time
[Music]
you